we're gonna start today with the White
House which accuses China of moving
trade talks backwards ahead of crucial
meetings this week President Trump says
negotiations are moving too slowly and
threatens more tariffs that could cost
Americans billions of dollars in higher
prices China's Vice Premier and economic
czar is coming to Washington on Thursday
one day before those new tariffs on
Chinese goods could take effect the
threat of the talks falling apart
rattled Wall Street yesterday but stocks
were covered most of their early losses
we Jiang is at the White House with the
new US posture on trade we Joe good
morning good morning or president
Trump's top trade negotiator Robert
light Heiser said China was reneging on
prior commitments to reach a trade deal
and that was unacceptable to the
president right Heiser told reporters
the US will more than double tariffs on
two hundred billion dollars of Chinese
goods on Friday he and Treasury
secretary Stephen minuchin were in
Beijing last week on Monday they said
China was offering less than what it had
promised in past negotiations but did
not specify what exactly had changed
from the original proposal the
administration is using the threat of
tariffs to pressure China to live up to
its prior commitments a report from a
pro trade group estimates that a tariff
increase to 25% would cost the average
family of four seven hundred and
sixty-seven dollars per year and the US
could lose almost 1 million jobs
China's commerce ministry said today the
Vice Premier is still planning to visit
the u.s. on Thursday and Friday keeping
some hope alive that progress can still
be made Norah we should let me ask you
about that battle joined yesterday when
the Treasury Department and Steven
ushion said no no no to the House
Democrats who've wanted presidents
Trump's on tax returns is this a legal
battle where does it go from here yeah
that is very likely the case that it
will end up in court secretary minuchin
called the request unprecedented and
said after consulting with the
Department of Justice decided that a
twacks legitimate legislative purpose
minuchin says the DOJ will provide more
detailed legal justification soon now
Democrats can either sue or subpoena the
IRS the chairman of the Ways and Means
can
is among the only lawmakers though that
can actually request those returns and
congressman Richard Neal says he is
going to consult with counsel and decide
the appropriate response
I'll stay tuned we should thank you